what was the horrific original ending to
a Disney movie and why did the Harry
Potter films feel the need to cut a
specific subplot these book scenes were
just too much for the movies
the Twilight Saga adapted the four
volumes of Stephanie Meyer's book series
into five movies splitting Breaking Dawn
into two parts and on the whole it does
a pretty good job of sharing most of the
Cullen family backstories Rosalie was
brutalized by her fiance Emmett was
nearly killed by a bear and Jasper was a
confederate soldier during the Civil War
patriarch Carlisle saved Edward and Esme
from near death and he himself was
turned by a coven of vampires in the
1600s the only person in the Cullen
family whose backstory we don't learn in
the movies is Alice my dear dear Alice
was so glad to see you here after all
Alice was born a human with precognitive
abilities and dealt with most of the
people in her hometown shunning her
because they thought she was cursed
after the death of her mother Alice
discovered that her father and his new
wife's father conspired to kill her
mother in order to keep her quiet
Alice's father had her committed to an
asylum where she underwent a brutal
experiments and lost her memory after a
lateral shock therapy while it would
have been good to learn more about Zales
in the movie Her traumatic experience
would have been very difficult to
portray on screen without risking the
film series appeal to pre-teen girls who
are more interested in the central
Romance of the movie The Shining is one
of the most lauded horror movies of all
time and certainly one of Stephen King's
most famous novels part of what makes a
movie so good is its ability to create
anxiety tension and fear without
countless overt displays of Gore
all right
[Music]
in the novel Jack Torrance begins a
story as a family man with writer's
block who's trying to provide a good
life for his wife and son Danny he
slowly descends into madness as he open
a hotel of which he is the winter
caretaker comes to possess his mind and
body towards the end of the book Jack is
chasing Dany with a rogue Mallet when he
is able to briefly take control of his
body back from the malevolence of the
hotel jacking treats Danny to run away
and bashes his own face in with the
Mallet in order to prevent himself from
pursuing his son in the movie Jack
enters the film a suspicious figure from
the start and becomes even more deranged
as the story moves forward the film
version of Jack never recovers himself
for even a second as he chases his wife
and child until the grounds of the
Overlook audiences were spared the Gory
mullet scene because Jack wasn't a
loving father in the film version of the
story instead we watch as he nearly acts
as his wife and son to death before
they're able to escape Jack then frees
us to death in the hotel maze face
intact despite the fact that JK
Rowling's seven book Harry Potter series
was a adopted into eight movies a lot of
content still needed to be cut from the
films to save time there are dozens of
chapters and subplots that were altered
or entirely removed from the film
adaptations and it's not surprising that
one of them was spew in the novel Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire Hermione
comes to learn more about the plight of
house elves in The Wizarding World most
of her horror how cells have been
enslaved by Wizards for centuries and
Hermione takes issue with this inspired
by Dobby's desire to escape Lucius
Malfoy's ownership Hermione begins an
organization called The Society for the
preservation of Elvish welfare master
has presented Dobby with clothes
Toby is free unfortunately for Hermione
Rowling writes about spew as if it's a
joke characters use synonyms for spew
think bath or hell and the elves at
Hogwarts come to resent Hermione for
attempting to free them since the fourth
book's release Hermione's organization
has been a source of great debate and
controversy within the Harry Potter
fandom so it's no wonder they decided to
leave it out of the movies the film
adaptation of Fight Club directed by
David Fincher and based on the novel of
the same name by Chuck palahnik didn't
do incredibly well at the box office but
has since become a cult favorite the
movie follows its narrator as he becomes
a comrade of Tyler Durden an
anti-capitalist anarchist who seeks to
disrupt America's consumerist society
and who starts a bare knuckle fight club
an exit or procedure 30 000 feet
um
the illusion of safety the movie shows
plenty of violence but some of the worst
stuff in the books was still omitted for
the screen adaptation in chapter 28 for
example the narrator having realized
that Tyler Durden is his own alter ego
and a figment of his imagination goes to
a fight club and arranges to fight 50
men in a row he's practically pulverized
he bites up a chunk of his own tongue at
one point and a wound in his cheek is
ripped open much wider so his teeth are
visible through his face there's still
plenty of brutality in the movie but it
isn't hard to see why this moment didn't
make the cut
it's hard to imagine why Disney thought
Victor Hugo's a hunchback of Notre Dame
would make a good animated musical
marketed toward a family audience the
original novel centers around a 16 year
old Romani girl in Paris named Esmeralda
and all the men who lust after her
Quasimodo The titular character falls
deeply in love with Esmeralda after she
defends him from humiliation but she
also captures the attention of his
reluctant Father Figure Claude frollo by
the way Great Mouse
in the movie frolo says Esmeralda up to
be killed after she rejects his advances
but Quasimodo saves her even though
Quasimodo doesn't end up with Esmeralda
he's finally accepted into society and
they all live happily ever after in the
book however frollo arranges for
Esmeralda to be hanged and watches her
die from the balcony of the cathedral
Quasimodo for the rage at the death of
his love pushes frolo off the balcony
killing him later on Quasimodo visits
Esmeralda's grave and sits there until
he starves to death clearly that's not
exactly as standard Disney ending so
some crucial changes were required to
make it more suitable for their target
audience
Trainspotting based on a novel by the
same name by Irvin Welsh is a gritty
film about heroin addicts Renton the
protagonist experiences withdrawals and
relapses throughout the story and does
many brutal often gross things in order
to either abstain from drugs or find
them
what's on the menu this evening sir the
movie doesn't shy away from the
grotesque elements of drug addiction but
there's one scene in the book that
didn't make it into the film in the book
Renton attends his brother's funeral and
hooks up with his brother's girlfriend
in the toilet while this is problematic
it's made worse by the fact that she's
heavily pregnant as in she could go into
labor at any moment Renton wonders for
himself whether sex with a very pregnant
person can be considered a threesome and
then knows that his private area is very
pungent because he hasn't showered in a
while it's a whole new rock bottom for
rented in the books and one that isn't
needed in the film Stephen King's
characters don't always survive his
stories but many different film
adaptations have sought to leave the
audience with a more hopeful ending such
as a case with Cujo a Stephen King
adaptation released in 1983. the film
stays mostly true to the book thanks to
the relatively straightforward plot and
premise a dog is infected with rabies
and kills people however the movie
ending is much less tragic the character
of Donna spends most of the movie
attempting to protect her young son from
Cujo by hiding in their broken Ford
Pinto but it's a hideout Tad and Donna
suffer from a heat stroke and
dehydration and Donna tries to escape
the car with her son in order to save
him it's not a monster it's just a doggy
in the novel by the time Cujo was killed
by Donna's husband Vic Tad has already
died from heat stroke and Donna sits on
the ground wailing over his lifeless
body the end luckily in the film Tad
makes it out alive
the novel Life of Pi by Jan Martell was
adapted to film by director Ang Lee in
2012. due to the unique narrative
structure of the novel which is told in
retrospect by an older pie who takes
time to explain things or ruminate on
ideas the screenplay needed to make
changes in order to make the story work
in a visual medium I I don't know how to
adapt this I mean I should just stuck
with my own stuff I don't know why I
thought I could write this one of the
least surprising changes from the books
of the movie takes place when Pai finds
himself on the light boat with a hyena
zebra and an orangutan named orange
juice in the book of pie and the animals
coexists on the boat for a while as the
hyena circles the wounded zebra finally
against the wishes of the orangutan the
hyena rips into the zebra and eats him
very graphically when Iran you sang
protests she's beheaded by the hyena in
the movie most of the gore happens off
camera thankfully and orange Juice's
wounds are minimal she dies but at least
the audience has spared the visual of a
headless corpse Jody Pico's
award-winning novel My Sister's Keeper
was adapted for film in 2009 starring
Cameron Diaz and Abigail Breslin the
movie follows the Fitzgerald Family
which consists of the parents Sarah and
Brian and their three children Kate
Jesse and Anna after Kate is diagnosed
with leukemia Sarah and Brian conceive
Anna in order to provide Kate with
whatever blood and Marrow donations she
needs for a treatment the story follows
Anna she asked for medical emancipation
for my parents she wants the power to
choose whether or not she donates parts
of herself to her sister Sarah is
particularly upset with Anna until it's
revealed that Kate asked Anna to do it
because she wants to enter cancer battle
and spare her family any more pain hey
baby what's your son cancer you're a
cancer no I'm Malia but I have cancer
the movie's ending is predictable Anna
doesn't donate her kidney to Kate and
Kate eventually passes away but in the
book it's actually Anna who dies the
point of the novel was to ruminate on
the unpredictable often meaningless
nature of death by having Anna pass away
in a car accident after becoming
emancipated Kate receives her late
sister's kidney and lives and it's this
ending among other things that make the
novel so much more merciful than its
film adaptation
easily the most controversial scene in
Stephen King's 1986 horror novel it
takes place when after the losers Club
defeats the titular evil entity our
pre-teen protagonists get lost in the
dairy to a system the group's loan
female Beverly comes up with a plan to
help unite the group in order to survive
she must have sex with each of the six
boys oddly enough this works as one of
the boys remembers how to escape the
sewer system after his sexual experience
unsurprisingly there's no childhood
suicide party in any on-screen version
of it screenwriter Gary Doberman told
Entertainment Weekly while it's an
important scene it doesn't Define the
book in any way and it shouldn't we knew
what the intent was of that scene and
why he put it in there and we tried to
accomplish what the intent was in a
different way but wait what was King's
intent naturally people had questions in
a message board post King explained I
wasn't really thinking of the sexual
aspect of it the book dealt with
childhood and adulthood the sexual act
connected childhood and adulthood times
have changed since I wrote that scene
and there is now more sensitivity to
those issues perhaps but it was still
pretty weird in the 80s
when thinking of Stanley Kubrick's 1971
film adaptation of Anthony burgess's
dystopian crime novel a club work orange
many people were called the ultra
violent scene in which Alexander's gang
of drugs Invader home and force the
owner to watch while they rape his wife
with said scene in place it's hard to
believe anything from the book got cut
he's enterprising aggressive
young bold vicious he'll do but the
scene in question comes after Alex meets
a couple of Lollipop looking girls at
the Record Shop takes him home and tells
what appears to be a consensual fast
motion threesome said to the William
Tell Overture in the book however the
encounter is a lot less friendly and the
girls are apparently only quote 10 years
young sexual violence against a grown
woman was already pushing it but sexual
violence against two girls that's too
much even for a Kubrick film
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest National Network website or
contact Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656 Hope 4673
foreign